[Music]
welcome back to cbs
this morning we begin with this the
family of a 13 year old boy with autism
is demanding answers after
a utah police officer shot him several
times newly released body cam footage
shows the moments before the shooting
has happened in the town of glendale
earlier this month
lyndon cameron's mother called police to
help calm the situation
and get him some help there are now
three investigations underway looking
into this shooting jamie yukas has the
story for us
including that video which we have to
warn you is difficult to watch
get on the ground this was the violent
result after lyndon cameron's mother
called police to request help for her 13
year old son
who has autism
[Applause]
hey show me your hands show me your
hands
i don't feel good show me your hands
the officer fired 11 shots bullets
tore through linden's shoulder both
ankles intestines and bladder
but he survived he was running away
he was running away his mother golda
barton had called 9-1-1
earlier saying her son was having a
mental breakdown
and she needed help getting him to the
hospital she asked for a crisis
intervention officer
my son has severe severe he does not
like cops
at all and so that's why we need a
mental health
worker instead four police officers
arrived on scene
barton told them her son may have had
access to a bb gun or prop gun
but she didn't believe he had it on him
i don't believe it's a road gun
i don't believe it's a relative so
unfortunately we have to kind of treat
them all as if they are
i know stop get on the ground knock it
off
officers confronted him in his backyard
and he ran his mother had warned the
officers that her son feared police
because sheriff's deputies shot and
killed her father in january
he sees the badge and he automatically
thinks like you're going to kill him
or he has to defend himself in some way
two of the officers expressed concern
about approaching him
honestly we can call sergeant and tell
them the situation because i'm not about
to get into shooting
because he's upset get on the ground
get on the ground police released the
body camera footage monday
chief mike brown called for more
resources to deal with the mental health
crisis
as a police department we want to be
partners with those who provide
mental health services as a community we
need to find a way forward
he's a small child why don't you just
tackle him
you are big police officers with massive
amounts of resources
come on give me a break what was it like
for you to watch that video
the worst thing i've ever watched in my
life his father michael cameron says his
little buddy has a long road to recovery
ahead of him
he has a heart of gold you know even
when he was a baby he tried to do all
the stuff i did
and he's definitely grown up to be a
an awesome young man how do you see
being able to help him move on from this
it's going to take a lot of work i'm
afraid and
you know it's going to be tough for him
the officer that fired the shots has
been placed on administrative leave
that's per standard protocol
salt lake city police officers are
required to go through
a 40 hour course of instruction that
covers mental health issues in relation
to police work
at the press conference earlier this
week chief brown did not
explain why the officer felt the need to
fire at lyndon
anthony jamie thank you boy that video
is difficult to watch a 13 year old kid
and i'm wondering if 40 hours of mental
health training is enough that doesn't
cut it it doesn't cut it
especially when you think how the family
was calling for help saying look he has
issues
yes it's a toy gun i understand why the
officer said we can't take your word for
it but it didn't appear to see
a gun there and i don't understand why
there so many shots are fired at that
moment
when he is a kid i don't know why look
police want to fight
criminals they don't want to be in that
situation either exactly if i'm running
a police union i'd be saying get us the
mental health benefits or the help that
we need for these situations yeah but
i'm wondering sometimes if the police
should say we're not trained for this
this is not what we should be doing
exactly i just it's it's just a tragic
success he survived but
his dad said it's a long road for him
for sure a lot of injuries